who the hell are you Jennifer Walters
attorney at law
not only am I being a superhero but I'm
also getting to do a comedy the triggers
are angry and fear those are like the
Baseline of any woman just existing
I was a huge fan of She-Hulk and she was
so strong and she broke the fourth wall
perfect
he's so excited to have this other
person but she's so far ahead of him
we all want to be She-Hulk but we relate
to being Jen Walters and Tatiana made me
change the way I think about this
character it's been so much fun cue the
training montage yes the fun of the show
is to combine This legal World superhero
weirdness wow this is quite a group all
of the guest stars are amazing who
doesn't want to hook up with daredevil
on his last day Benedict Was DJing
longers
[Music]
She-Hulk smash a symbol to making her
She-Hulk now streaming She-Hulk attorney
at law all episodes now streaming only
on Disney plus get over there